gentlemen it has been a pleasure and an
honor to meet you and uh your your
people the U.S government support you in
every possible way
ideologically of course
however we cannot offer any military aid
at this time with all due respect
Ambassador we need more than that we are
dealing with terrorism on a daily basis
oh that's unfortunate we Warlords
overrun Villages yes that's a
regrettable leaps torches all manner of
human atrocities that's really sad but
the US military is simply spread too
thin we can't afford another
intervention at this time
but what we could use your help with
really is protecting our vulnerable
plentiful and newly discovered oil
reserves oil
excuse me one second
operation Golden Eagle is a go
uh we also have natural gases oh yes a
lot lots of it
show me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for it
you can't play me mothers
I'm the mother that plays [__]
[Music]
cut
all right everybody let's get reset we
are going again
Nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an American tough wow I'm
just so glad that we got you out of that
BBC commitment so you can play with us
Cheers Cheers Antoine listen I'm just
now buying that you're someone that was
born and raised in the streets of
Brooklyn
that's weird because uh I actually was
born and raised on the streets of
Brooklyn
I wasn't a gang and everything most of
this stuff actually happened to me wow
okay well that's that's that's great for
us because I want you to use it okay
it's good first take let's just uh let's
get going let's go let's get going thank
you Jim
scene five take two
and action
you sold me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for me
you can't play me brother
I'm the [__] that plays mother
his mother
cut cut
okay uh Nigel that was great oh
brilliant just the way you move
especially when you talk I just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes cheers it's fabulous Antoine
your performance
um
not quite there yet okay I really need
to see you make more of a transformation
okay like like Nigel here
that dude's British
Antoine if I might jump in with a bit of
advice
caramel maybe you might want to try
thinking of something in the material
that's similar to something that's
happened in your real life
for me for instance I like to think of
when my mom wanted me to attend Prep
School in Leeds to become a barrister
but I wanted to study the theater at
Oxford thank God and so that was a
conundrum really for me I'm gonna stop
you right right there because it's just
confusing me right like I don't need
that because I am from the streets I was
in a gang
they told me to kill my cousin
might be a fit Sports hard no yeah
that's a bit spawn on do you have any
stories that involve your mom
what's a mum
yeah scene five take three
okay
Antoine remember you're a gangster okay
betrayal the streets
okay Nigel you're perfect and one
transform and action
show me out son
now you're gonna get a blood up in your
head for it
you can't play me mother
I'm the [__] that plays
[__]
he's boring to watch
cut
oh that does not sound good
do not feel like you have found the
emotional core of this character this
nobody is more real than me okay I come
from the streets and nobody's gonna tell
me what the streets is like nobody you
understand
that's a great speech I just wish that I
believed it you want to give it a shot
so I'll have a go move
you're near me you are from the from the
from the Earth from these streets
something to that defense no but I am so
with you I'm with you when you say that
even when you're saying the wrong words
I just wish you could do that
oh goodness
okay that hurts but I don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional place for
the character all right here give it a
shot give me watch watch
oh that's that's great I feel that in
here and in here
let's try that again
I just I don't I don't believe you
okay let's get this thing going
everybody take a seat
we gotta have more meetings homes
I'm telling you man we gotta get
organized
[Music]
Carlito ain't got a seat man someone get
him a chair nah I'm cool no dude get him
at your homes nah man
I'm gonna sit gangster but Carlito it
doesn't look like he's comfortable man
why don't you just sit in the chair
I never sit in a chair essay
you never ever gonna catch me sitting in
no chairs
like I said you know that that's local
right
um
it's cool Carlito No One's Gonna think
you're soft if you sit in a chair yes
we're all sitting in chairs hey a bunch
of [__] ass culeros okay I don't have
no time to sit in a [__] chair
huh
okay
now that we're all here
you know what but why though like it
don't make no sense for you to set
yourself up with the rule like that no
it's like limiting yeah limiting I mean
sometimes people sit in chairs man all
of you guys with your [__] ass cherry
there
okay Carlito quit playing and sit in the
chair open the hole no Carlito we have
to have this meeting now and say get up
I'm good right here man you know
chilling go ahead with your meaning okay
but you know it's gonna be weird
you don't care it's gonna be weird weird
for you maybe
he doesn't care okay
okay homies so this is what we have to
do
like we gotta sum on drugs and we gotta
make more crimes happen
Roberto where are we
Carlito you're bleeding essay
who cares man
oh
you just got saved man we gotta pull
that out leave it
I'm chilling homes
I don't care about that stupid Shank
Ito
wake up man
don't even bother essay
I don't need those defibrillator
I don't even want to come back to life
homes where
go back into your body my body's stupid
homes
I'm fine right here on the spirit plane
life is for [__]
[Music]
no I'm good man Carlito that's Heaven
man I don't need to go to heaven humps
Heaven is for [__] oh boy
oh well
man do not get me started on the
Mexicans hey
I just say it
they hold the goddamn economy together
you know what man damn straight if 12 of
the Mexicans who live in this country
stop working just 12 percent
the USA
damn
I don't care who hears me no they they
they they they work their asses off and
they got strong family values essential
immigrants hey speaking of immigrants
how about them Asians you know what
brother you want to lap that fears and
you better stand back cause I got
something I want to say about those
mother I got three words for you
studious hard-working industrious damn
straight Asians are the highest income
best educated in the fastest growing
racial group in the USA plus got the
highest percentage of college graduates
in the country good for them and maybe
this makes me sound racist but those
mothers
They're Gonna Save the country there it
is you said you went and said it I just
said I just came right out and said it
was in everyone's mind but I'm the one
who said it hey and you know what while
we're at it I'm gonna break my spawn tip
tap dancing Ransom prancing around the
elephant in the room yep blacks blacks
[__] blacks you know what you're done
done dead you opened up the blood Gates
now my friend release the Kraken goddamn
victims the institutionalize racism
[Applause]
and I mean that's just true right there
that's this historical fact man can't
even argue that
ah oh how about the Indians in Native
Americans
I don't know if I would get in trouble
these days these different things like
this but they were here first it may be
unpopular but it's true we we came to
this country and we steamrolled on in
and we genocided them I mean hell we owe
them something there you go
[Music]
I gotta tell you man that's not bad for
a non-alcoholic beer not bad at all all
right I gotta go home take care of my
kids how many of them you got now just
adopted the 11th oh can't help myself
man that's always what happens when you
volunteer for the earthquake relief in
Haiti
you know my wife makes two-thirds of
what I mean what y'all got the same job
man that's just patently unfair that's
right we're both Librarians you all
right I'm okay
you guys see anything
okay
we'll uh wait until dark
and then sneak back across the line
and rejoin our unit
did you guys hear something
oh
please Americans prove to be no obstacle
at all
search the hotel yeah
we've done well to secure this position
I could bode well for promotion
speaking of which
guess what I saw at the market the other
day
oh oh I don't know Adolf Hitler
I love Hitler who doesn't but you ever
see him in person oh yeah at the
Nuremberg rally it was very
inspirational I know it was I was there
everyone was there but up close it's a
whole different thing for instance it
was the weekend and that little hairs
were just started to grow on the sides
of the mustache like this sold I walk up
to Hitler casual El comment on that's
that's rude I'm in the middle of a story
you're not interested in a story about
our Fiola yeah okay good Ava was there
as well taller than you think or hit the
shorter hard to say but anywho
I'm buying some bread Hitler's buying
some bread
um I must so I'm I'm assuming you've got
a better Hitler story but no but maybe
don't interrupt
yes sir so I gave him a salute and he
gives me one of those half Hitler
salutes you know down low very cool
right you know here's what you forget
yeah
doesn't say Heil Hitler isn't that funny
I can't wait I think maybe next time
I'll tell him how uninterested you are
in my story no no this is jealousy thing
no no no no I didn't meet Hitler to hurt
your feelings
isn't it
proceed of course
so I say to Hitler I've actually been
quite busy he had a laugh and then says
you and me both I mean he's the Fiora
it's so funny because it's an
understatement I mean he's super busy as
Hitler was taking his lead I have to
interrupt you right do you speak during
the cinema the story has a build
but if you keep interrupting you kill
the momentum what I'm trying to tell you
that body is moving
that's ridiculous the Americans are all
dead
but if it keeps you from interrupting my
awesome Hitler story
I'll prove it to you
very good
[Music]
thank you
I'll never get used to those final death
goes death throws
what is wrong with you those are not
death throws you are being an idiot
[Music]
insubordinate
and cherish
pity
this is the best part of the story as
Hitler was taking his leave of me he
said well there's no point in getting
blood if you're not going to get and at
the same time Hitler said she's I said
trees and then Hitler and I both said
Jinx well there's just like two regular
everyday peoples you guys missed the
first part but this is all about Hitler
so fine she was drunk on barley wine I'd
been to Sea for months or three I knew I
could make her mine but the last was
past consent so it was off with her we
went and we threw her in bed and rested
her head and we laughed cause that's
what gentlemen do
hold on
[Music]
we don't say oh that's always
disrespectful
there once was a Gala from Leeds who I
heard was good on her knees so I docked
my ship for an overnight trip to take
care of all my needs just fine
10 and my mask began to swell so I laid
her down and raised her down and
performed cunnilingus for an hour or so
[Applause]
[Music]
I once had a woman so fair whose wound
contained my air with a Sun by my side
the Seas we'd ride the child she would
bear but my girl she was no fool she was
working her way through school so I did
support when she chose to abort because
it's her body in there for her choice
[Applause]
[Music]
there was a lady with a golden eye and
the doctor said she would die so she
emptied her purse to lift the curse and
prayed to stay alive she awoke the very
next day hand in her grave she lay but
the scariest part of the story from the
start is I bet you assumed the doctor
was a man
foreign
[Music]
thank you
cause it's your whole but we don't say
ho
ES
[Applause]
[Music]
okay